check out this week's must see movies in  Dunkirk Christopher Nolan tells an epic  true story of a massive military  evacuation during World War two in five  minutes you guys  we need a girls trip for lifelong  friends go on a girls trip to New  Orleans and rekindle their sisterhood  with little drinking and dancing you  have less than ten hours to find the  threat to agents raced to save the  universe in mullerian in the city of a  thousand planets we need the two of you  to be the guardians of our future see  what's hot in theaters with this week's  fantasy patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]